- Hey everyone, thanks for joining us.
This is an amazing conference.
There's so many people around.
Thank you for taking the time
out of your busy schedule
to join us here.
How's everybody's conference so far?
It's good?
- Yeah.
- Amazing response. Okay, great.
So my name's Jesse Butler, I
am a Principal Product Manager
in the Amazon EKS Service Team.
I'm joined by my colleague Sriram.
- Hey everyone, I'm Sriram Ranganathan.
I'm a Product Manager with
the Amazon EKS Service Team.
- So we're really excited to talk with you
about something we've been
working on for several months
called Amazon EKS capabilities.
So I'm gonna start with some context,
go through sort of some of the theory
of why we built this set of features
and how we hope they will benefit you.
And then Sriram will come back up
and dive into some of the details.
So just starting with
kind of setting context,
if anybody's seen any of
the launch announcements,
you know that this is
related to platform services
and growing sort of
your cluster experience
through these foundational
services for GitOps,
I like this quote from Alan Kay,
who's the father of the
SmallTalk programming language,
object oriented programming.
"Simple things should be simple,
complex things should be possible."
This is a great analog to abstractions.
Like why do we abstract things in systems?
A little bit more on
point to our discussion
is one from Dijkstra,
"The purpose of abstraction
is not to be vague,
but to be creating a new semantic level
in which one can be absolutely precise."
This is a better sort of
software engineering concept
around abstractions.
We don't wanna hide the abstractions
because of the complexity
under abstractions,
because often there's
power in them, right?
If you look at AWS or look at Kubernetes,
there's so much you can
do with that cluster.
The last thing we want to do
is put a sort of layer on top of it
that obfuscates, we want
to actually elevate.
So Kubernetes itself is an abstraction
or a set of abstractions
Kubernetes makes complex things possible.
We like to look at Kubernetes
as sort of the platform layer
for many customers, it's
the front door to AWS.
It's often said that
Kubernetes is complex itself.
I personally have worked on
fairly large software projects
scheduling thousands or hundreds
of thousands of processes
across hundreds or thousands of computers.
That is possible, but it is hard.
It takes a lot of concerted,
deep technical effort
and a lot of resources.
Kubernetes democratizes
scaled distributed computing,
and this isn't my opinion, right?
The world kind of agrees.
So 80% of enterprises are
using Kubernetes in production
with another 13% report piloting
or kind of investigating
for future adoption.
So this has become a defacto
standard in cloud computing
because it is a good abstraction
because it is a powerful way
to layer functionality into your systems.
So simplicity is one of the
things that we're looking for,
and we'll talk a little bit about how EKS
is one of our sort of tenets
of making simpler experiences
for our customers.
We also need to think
about consistency at scale.
This is where we have things
like declarative configuration
and how these kind of
cloud native practices
have come to be.
System consistency is incredibly important
at the scale that many of you operate at.
And if you're just getting
started in your scaling journey,
the scaling level that you aspire to,
consistency is paramount.
We also have extensibility
as a core requirement
for building platforms
in the modern world,
and Kubernetes is incredibly extensible.
These abstractions are good and powerful,
but you can also extend them
and build out any of your
own custom needs, right?
Into the cluster.
So one of those things
around extensibility
is kind of the result is
this huge vast ecosystem
of tools and projects that are available
for you to use, right?
Kubernetes itself is incredibly resilient
and very, very powerful,
but it is not itself an end-to-end
production ready application platform.
As many of you probably already
know, you need to do things,
you need to install things
in the cluster to make it be
what you need it to be to ship
and run software at scale.
So the CNCF has over 200
projects at this point,
hundreds of compatible tools,
this ecosystem is vast.
There's really unlimited customization.
Beyond that, you can
build your own controllers
and have your own custom
resources in the cluster
to do just about anything you want
from managing AWS cloud resources
to ordering Domino's pizzas.
When we look at simplicity
and all of that amazing
abstraction and extensibility,
we're really talking
about relative simplicity.
Kubernetes itself isn't a simple thing,
but it is relatively simple
when you compare it to other things.
For example, the Core system
has about 1,500 methods,
and AWS SDK has about 10,000.
Now these are vastly different things
with different purposes.
AWS is a bunch of features
and products and other things
that do a lot of things,
but there is relative simplicity
if you compare the two.
And what's nice with EKS
and using Kubernetes as
the front door to AWS,
is that you're able to capture
some of that complexity
and powerful primitives
that you can abstract
for your end users, or for yourself
as you're scaling your workloads.
So seven years ago when
we started Amazon EKS,
we launched it actually right
here at re:invent in 2017,
our main motivation was to
make Kubernetes more accessible
to AWS customers.
We knew that this
abstraction, this primitive
kind of, the set of primitives
and these kind of standards would evolve
and we were right, we're
very happy to have been right
because the growth of
EKS has been enormous.
EKS started as a managed
control plane, right?
So we knew that doing
Kubernetes the hard way
while educational was actually hard.
So the managed control
plane was where we started
and we've evolved ever
since with this mission
to help you build reliable and stable
and secure applications
with Kubernetes clusters.
And it's very important to note
that it's Kubernetes, it is
upstream compliant Kubernetes.
So we get to benefit from
all the extensibility
as well as you do.
So if we look at one of
the feature layers for EKS
around the data plane and node management.
So when we started with
that managed control plane,
we had self-managed nodes,
this was fine, right?
The real complex part
was in the control plane
and actually customers
wanted self-managed nodes,
they wanted that autonomy.
And over time, that became burdensome
to manage all of those nodes directly.
And so we put a lifecycle, API on it
with managed node groups allowing you
to create groups of nodes
that you could manage
with API calls and manage that lifecycle.
Moving to last year at re:invent,
we announced auto mode,
which is a fully end-to-end
fully managed data plane.
So that gives you an
end-to-end push button cluster
where you just, you don't have
to worry about nodes at all.
We fully manage everything
as well as the storage
and networking integrations, right?
So this is an example
of the evolution of EKS,
starting with what we know
customers need at the moment
and evolving over time
based on your feedback
and also based on, you know,
where the direction of Kubernetes is going
as well as the direction of AWS.
So when customers start with
EKS, we're talking about
building and managing clusters, primarily.
And EKS makes it really
easy to do that, right?
At this point, with auto mode,
you go into the console,
you click a button,
rather than going and growing coffee beans
and roasting them and
making pots of coffee,
you can simply get a cup
of coffee from the kitchen
and come back and pretty
much have a cluster up
and ready to go.
So our mission since launch
is to then continuously improve
this cluster lifecycle management for you
to make that a better
experience over time.
Adding new feature layers
like auto mode, hybrid nodes,
these are all sort of
commitments toward that vision.
But when you look at
scaling your workloads
and using more clusters and
expanding your workloads
across multiple accounts
and multiple regions,
you're really scaling with Kubernetes.
EKS helps you build and manage
production-ready clusters.
It's up to you to manage
and scale your Kubernetes.
So workloads, networking
components, storage resource,
all the integrations that you have
plus any custom solutions that you need.
All of those things come into the cluster
and become things that you
manage maybe with Helm charts
or maybe with other methods.
This can work really well to get started
and even at scale, can work really well.
There's a lot of people that
are very good at automation,
are very good at governance,
but as scale continues,
you have more regions, more accounts,
depending on how autonomous
your teams need to be.
Compliance gets hard, auditing gets hard,
and scale just brings
more operational burden.
So if we look at how most customers
are dealing with cluster
management beyond the API,
there's a lot of Terraform
use, some CloudFormation
and we're seeing some Kubernetes IaC.
So what we have here is
sort of the imperative
external to the cluster
IaC, mostly Terraform
and this works really well.
We have version controlled
declarative configuration
that's reconciled against
a source of truth.
Terraform does its thing
and you get a cluster,
and this can work as you
scale as well, right?
Having two or three teams going
across a couple of regions.
As you start to scale, this
can work incredibly well,
but at some point we do
hit a point of friction.
We experience this problem
where there's just too many.
either too many cooks in the kitchen
or there's too many pipelines
for one small team to manage.
And if something goes wrong,
we end up in this position
of trying to find where it
went wrong, how to remedy it,
who even owns it, right?
This can be a problem with scale.
So we start with single clusters
and you want to get to this
all seeing all dancing,
cross region, cross
account, scalable thing.
How do customers who have
been most successful with EKS
get there?
What we see is that there's
this inflection point
around the point where multiple
clusters come into the mix
and you want to get to that next level
of abstraction and automation.
This is the point where
we see a lot of customers
start investing pretty heavily
in dedicated platform
engineering resources.
We move away from sort
of decentralized teams
and more toward a structured
platform engineering path
to get you to the next level.
This is something that we see commonly
with all of our most scaled customers,
but all of them do it
a little differently.
This is bespoke investment, right?
There is engineering work to be done here
that is not necessarily the business logic
that you wanna ship to customers.
At our largest customers,
there's dedicated platform teams
whose customers are the internal
development teams, right?
So this is a place where
we see a lot of investment
and a lot of commonality, but
things are slightly different.
One thing that is true
is that these platform engineering efforts
follow these sort of core
cloud native characteristics
that we see in Kubernetes
and also repeated
throughout the ecosystem.
Declarative configuration
and continuous reconciliation
are things that are just the
kind of bread and butter,
primitive of these systems.
Programmatic discoverability
and observability.
These are really important at scale.
You know, if you wanna run 400 clusters
with a team of five
people, you need to be able
to automate and you need to be
able to watch where you are.
Active drift detection itself,
automated self-healing is really
a sort of Holy Grail, right?
Wouldn't it be great if the system
using its underlying primitives
could keep itself whole, right?
What if an imperative change comes in?
What if something fails?
Can something automatically
fix that at 2:00 AM for me
and slack me so I can see
it with my morning coffee
rather than getting paged
at 2:00 AM in the morning?
And on top of all of this,
we want these things
to be standards based.
You know, Linux took off
because it wasn't the best
operating system on the planet,
it was an open standard
that we could all contribute
to and make better.
That's what we see with Kubernetes.
It's an open standard, it's
portable and it's governed.
So when we look at these characteristics
and we think about Kubernetes,
we check all of the boxes, right?
This is how the system was built.
And I think it's important to note
that as we start looking at
something like EKS capabilities
and wondering, do we need this?
Do I need this in my world?
We often find that people
who are new to Kubernetes
and new to DevOps are learning
DevOps through Kubernetes.
They start using Kubernetes
and they find that these things
are the aspects of the system,
where in fact these are kind
of just DevOps best practices
that through trial of fire and ice
have become the principles and
the standards that we know.
Kubernetes was designed with
these principles in mind.
So we see that Kubernetes is in fact
a reference implementation
of these underlying characteristics
that are ideal for systems.
The reality is that there is
no ideal system for everyone.
Every customer has different needs
and different requirements.
You may have different
governance and compliance
for restricted regulated workloads
and restricted environments
and just generally culture, right?
It's different across every customer.
Everybody has different needs.
So we can't say, oh, take
the GitOps off of the shelf
and I'll buy that product
and I'll just use it.
That's not how that works, right?
We have to think about
all of the different ways
that we have to keep the standards open
and keep the primitives
light so that you can build
what you need to in order to scale.
One thing that we see across
all of our most successful
scaled customers in EKS
are these common platform
foundational components.
Really looking at workloads
and infrastructure for cloud resources
and infrastructure for
the underlying clusters
and related, you know,
to production databases,
that kind of stuff.
These are the foundational components
that every team has to solve for,
you know, depending on
the line of business
or the culture or even the
the point of scale, right?
All the other things may be different,
but these are three things
that everyone has to
account for at some point
as we begin this scaling journey.
So we look to GitOps and I think
this was a very trendy and
buzzy word for a while.
We've been really
consistently guiding customers
toward GitOps since 2019 or 2020.
So since before it was a buzzword
and through it being a buzzword
and now it's no longer a buzzword.
I think of GitOps as a
reference implementation.
You know, it takes these best practices,
these cloud native system fundamentals
and sort of how we think of a system
running well in the cloud today
and it turns it into a
reference implementation.
These four characteristics are
what makes a GitOps system.
You can build it with Korn Shell scripts
on a Raspberry Pi if you want to
it doesn't have to be Kubernetes,
but it does have to have
its desired state expressed declaratively.
Declarative configuration is a requirement
for practicing GitOps.
That desired state is
immutable and versioned,
which just means if it's a YAML file,
it goes into Git, it's
versioned, then it's immutable.
The desired state is
automatically applied from source.
So when you push something to Git
it automatically ends up
in your running system.
Now these three first things
are anybody using Git and
doing Ops, that's GitOps.
The last one is most paramount.
And the thing that makes such
a good fit for Kubernetes
is the desired state is
continuously reconciled.
So that means imperative changes
that come in from a junior
admin who hits the wrong button
all the way through to nodes falling over
and having to repair themselves
through a software update.
All of these things come through
from the system out, not imperatively
from you getting paged
at two in the morning.
So the desired state is reconciled
by agents within the system.
This is probably the most
defining characteristic
of what a GitOps system is
and that's why Kubernetes
is such a good match.
So GitOps, using this
reference implementation,
we can work toward
building ideal platforms.
We can't build ideal
systems for everybody.
Everybody has different requirements,
but the platform can be an ideal.
And one of the things
we were motivated to do
earlier this year is
to see if we could find
some commonality and some
things that we could help
provide in EKS as native features
to help with this practice of GitOps
for workloads, for cloud resources,
and for clusters themselves.
You know, building a
fleet management system
has never been possible for us
because every other customer we talk to
has wildly different requirements.
So with this reference of
implementation being extensible,
you can actually your own
and we can help support you with that.
So GitOps works really well
and it is open source software
that's usually happening
on the Kubernetes cluster.
For example, Argo CD, you
might use ACK or Crossplane
for cloud resources or any
number of other solutions.
Argo CD is kind of a defacto standard.
So looking at the system, you'd say,
yes, okay, now we have manageable growth.
And you can add more clusters
and you can manage with
a single control plane
those deployments and you
can add more clusters.
And eventually we end up in this situation
where we're scaling out
decentralized GitOps environments,
which are based on open source
that you're self-managing in your clusters
and we're kind of back
in the same position.
So we see teams ending
up spending time here
and this is where the shift
to we need dedicated
platform teams comes in.
We end up managing the thing
that helps us abstract things away,
but we end up kind of having to manage
the problems with that
abstraction and then you end up
just chasing your own
tail and then you end up
with issues in a system like this as well.
So Kubernetes based platforms,
this is the way that you scale,
but we think that we have
a way to help you do it
a little more efficiently
with that foundational,
bespoke complexity being
something that we handle.
And if you look again back
at our feature evolution
this time thinking about
things in your cluster,
we start with Helm charts.
We point you to the CNCF
and say have a nice time.
There's 4,000 Helm charts, right?
EKS add-ons was a step
in the right direction,
just like managed no groups.
It puts a lifecycle API
around some of the most commonly
used operational add-ons.
So what comes next?
That's why we're really
excited to introduce you
to EKS capabilities.
So this is the first time
that EKS has had a new feature layer.
We expect a full part of
the roadmap dedicated here.
We're really excited
about this, that this,
we're moving beyond
managing cluster lifecycle
to also help you build
and scale with Kubernetes,
with your clusters.
So with EKS capabilities, you're able
to kind of click a button,
just start using these things.
They will evolve as you
evolve by using them.
We're gonna be adding more
features and more refinements,
but you'll be able to increase
your velocity from day one.
Remove some of that friction.
If you're just starting out
on your scaling journey,
this is a great place to start,
even if it feels like it's all too much
and you won't need it, if
you start using GitOps,
either open source, self-managed,
or with capabilities
with a few clicks of a button,
which we'll talk about
in a few moments here,
we'll dive into some of the details.
But starting here, means
you're ready for the future.
That means you won't ever have to do
that refactoring and figuring out
how to put all the fires
out while you're doing it.
You just start with these primitives
and you're ready to scale.
It's all open.
It's all based on
Kubernetes open standards.
Right now, the three
capabilities that we've launched
are all based on well-known
open source projects.
They're either defacto standards,
emerging kind of innovations
or things that AWS stands behind
with a capital S, support.
So these are all things
that customers already use
and are interested in using more of.
So Argo CD is where our
GitOps engine comes in.
This is used by most of our
customers practicing GitOps.
Argo CD has really emerged
as its own defacto standard
alongside of Kubernetes.
What we do see a lot is this
use of Argo CD is self-managed
and predominantly driven
out of the platform team.
A lot of customers actually use Argo CD
particularly for their platform
where their development customers
aren't actually using it
to deploy workloads at
all, using, you know,
imperative pipelines with
Bash scripts and Jenkins
has worked just fine.
And so we see this kind of
coming out of the platform team
and starting to evolve.
We also have ACK and Kro,
which gives us the infrastructure part.
Another piece that we see with customers
who are practicing GitOps
and some for years,
really enjoying it, having
a lot of success with it,
they stop short of managing
infrastructure with it.
They only work on, for
example, cluster add-ons
or maybe some just do internal workloads.
What we think the real
power in the system is
when you can bring cloud
infrastructure to the party
and start managing your clusters,
your workload resources,
everything together, so Kro
and ACK help you do that.
So really quickly, I just want to be clear
before we dig into some of
the details of how these work,
this is what a diagram might look like
for a self-managed platform
with these software components.
You see EKS runs the cluster for you.
In our account we run
the entire control plane.
If you're using auto mode,
we'll also manage your nodes for you
and in your account, your
Helm chart installing Argo CD,
ACK and Kro and you have
the CRDs to work with
and you're creating applications
and resources and instances
and therefore having S3 buckets
and RDS instances in your accounts.
With EKS capabilities, we are
running all of the controllers
and their dependencies
in our service accounts
just like we do the
cluster control planes.
So Argo CD, ACK and Kro are
fully run in EKS infrastructure.
They don't take up compute resources
and other resources in your clusters.
They free up your compute
and your pod slots
for your workloads and
we manage the lifecycle,
patching, scaling and the
resilience and availability
of your capabilities for you.
We do install the CRDs in your cluster
so you're still in full
control of your applications
and your ACK resources
and other custom resources
that come through the capabilities.
So our vision for this new feature layer
is shown through the
three initial capabilities
that we're offering.
They're all open standards,
they're Kubernetes native experiences,
which we think is very vital.
You're choosing to use Kubernetes,
whether you're starting
out and ready to scale
or you've been with us for
years, you're choosing it in part
because it is a standard.
You have a standardization layer,
you have multiple
environments, multiple teams
potentially deploying workloads
to multiple cloud environments or on-prem.
You want that standardization.
So it's very important to us
as we build more features
and into the future,
that those are portable for you as well.
We want to reduce friction.
So these will be always
fully managed for you.
There will never be a capability
that runs or deploys
things to your cluster.
However, we might have
additional CRDs in the cluster
to actually help accelerate velocity
and help you fine tune
your configurations.
So we'll talk about,
IAMRoleSelectors with ACK in a bit,
but there might be others
of those in the future.
And we're also really excited
about new innovations.
So Kro, bringing Kro into EKS capabilities
is really the first time
in EKS where we've offered,
you know, not GA software, right?
This is software that is evolving.
It's something that the
community's really excited about
as recently was donated
to SIG cloud provider.
So it's very visible in the
ecosystem, but it is not GA.
I will clarify that EKS
capabilities are GA,
our ability to manage
and run that software
for you on your behalf is
fully generally available
in all commercial regions,
that's available where EKS is.
However, what you might find
is that we will lean into new innovations
and new trends in the Kubernetes ecosystem
and this is a way for us to
be able to do that for you.
So I think I'm gonna pass
it to my colleague, Sriram
is gonna dig into the features
and talk a little bit about the details.
Thank you.
- Thanks Jesse.
Hey everyone. So what is EKS capabilities?
EKS capabilities is an extensible
set of platform features
that extend your EKS clusters.
Unlike self-managed installations,
AWS fully manages all
EKS capabilities for you.
What this means is you don't
have any operational overhead.
You don't have to worry about
installation, configuration,
patching, upgrades,
all of that is automatically
taken care of by AWS.
If you try to kubectl into
your Kubernetes cluster
and try to find Argo CD controllers
or let's say for example ACK controllers,
you're not going to find them.
They run in AWS own service
accounts, they're fully managed
and that's why you won't
be able to find them.
How do you go about creating a capability?
All capabilities follow a common pattern
when it comes to creation.
When you create a capability,
you first have to identify
which capability you want,
you have to give it a name
so that you can refer to it later.
You have to decide which cluster
you want to enable the capability on,
and then you have to
pass an capability role.
Depending on the capability,
there might be some additional
configurations needed.
We will touch upon those as
we go through the next slides.
And just to note, all
of these capabilities
can be created using multiple modes.
You can do it through the CLI,
you can do it through eksctl,
any of your favorite IAC tools
or through the EKS console,
there are no restrictions.
So when we built EKS capabilities,
we have introduced a new service principle
that you see on screen here.
When you create the capability role,
you need to ensure that the trust policy
trusts this particular service principle.
This is key. It's not your OIDC provider.
It is the EKS capability
service principle.
You can always scope this
down to specific resources
by adding additional conditions.
Once you're done with the trust policy
now comes the time for permissions.
Depending on how you want
to use the capabilities
and what integrations you want,
you might need to add certain permissions
for each of the capability roles.
In case of Argo CD,
depending on if your source is coming from
let's say CodeCommit or from
ECR or from CodeConnections,
you have to give it
appropriate permissions.
With ACK, depending on the
AWS resources you plan to use,
you have to correspondingly
give the underlying permissions.
As an example, if you plan to use S3,
then you need to give S3 permissions.
If you plan to use RDS, you
need to give it RDS permissions.
With Kro, there are no
specific permissions required.
It is confined to the Kubernetes cluster,
but let's say for example,
if you plan to use ACK along with Kro,
then you need to make sure
that whatever AWS resources
are governed by the Kro RGD.
You have to give the
corresponding permissions
to the ACKs capability rule,
not to the Kro capability rule.
We will walk through hands-on examples
of three EKS capabilities.
Argo CD for automation
with deep AWS integration,
ACK for infrastructure provisioning
with scoped flexible IAM roles,
Kro for creating platform abstractions.
These are the building blocks
you decide how you want to use them.
What is Argo CD?
I know Jesse touched briefly
upon what is Argo CD.
Argo CD is a GitOps based
continuous deployment tool.
Your Git repository becomes
the source of truth.
And Argo CD ensures that
your cluster state matches
what you have defined in Git,
it supports drift detection
and automatic reconciliation,
what I mean by that
is if you go and make
an imperative change,
Argo CD can automatically detect it
and make sure that it brings
back your system state
back to the desired state
so that there is no drift.
You have options to turn that off,
but it is typically not the best practice.
One of the good things about
Argo CD is it lets you connect
a central Argo CD instance to
multiple different clusters.
So if you have applications
that needs to get deployed
to different clusters,
you can always do that
from a central cluster.
In this illustration, we
have the EKS capability,
which is an Argo CD capability
enabled on a central cluster
and you can connect multiple
different EKS clusters
and push your deployments to it.
The good thing is
these EKS clusters can
be in the same account,
different account, same
region, different region.
It does not matter.
You can connect to any EKS
cluster within your portfolio.
Typically, when you're connecting
to multiple different EKS
clusters and different accounts,
different VPCs, different regions,
you need to worry about the
networking aspect of it.
How do you do VPC pairing?
How do you set up transit gateways?
The cool thing about EKS capabilities
is you don't have to worry about any of it
that is fully managed for you.
You don't have to worry about
how to reach the clusters
we take care of that for you.
You just need to give us the cluster route
and we establish the connection.
Here is a specific example
of how do you go about
creating the actual Argo CD capability.
Here we have the type of
capability set as Argo CD.
We give it a name, we identify the cluster
to which Argo CD should be enabled on.
There is a role ARN,
which is nothing but the
Argo CD capability role
and in this particular case
we also have an additional configuration.
AWS EKS Argo CD capability is integrated
with AWS Identity Center.
This is how we enable single sign-on
for your Argo UI and Argo CLI.
So you need to ensure that
your identity center is enabled
and you pass on the identity
center configuration
when you are creating the capability.
This illustration is showing
how you can create the
same Argo CD capability,
if you're more comfortable with Console,
you can do it through the
Console, it's pretty simple.
Most of the information
is prefilled for you.
You just select the role,
select the identity center
provider and you click on next
and the capability will
get created for you.
In case you don't have a
role already available.
There is also a nice option available
wherein you can create the role directly
through the Console itself.
It is mainly for getting
started experience.
If you want, you can always scope it down
when you're going through
the role creation process,
but if you are okay with the
getting started experience,
you don't have to change anything.
Everything is prefilled for you.
You just need to agree to
it and it creates the role
and automatically selects it for you.
Once you create the role,
this is where you will land.
It gives you basic details about okay,
what is this capability?
When was it created? What is
the IAM corresponding to it?
And if there are any health issues or not.
At the top right corner you
see the capability issues.
If let's say, for example,
for whatever reason
you ran into an error or
degraded, you can click on it
and it'll give you details in
terms of what was the error
and how to recover from that.
Argo CD is fully managed
but you still have access
to your favorite Argos UI.
You also have access to Argo CLI.
You can configure that
from Argo UI perspective,
you don't have to anything.
We provide you the hyperlink
from the EKS Console.
You just click on it, you
enter your credentials
and you're logged into the Argo UI.
So there are no restrictions
compared to what you would do, typically,
with a self-managed installation.
Now that we have created the capability,
let's dive deeper into some
of the Argo CD core resources.
One of the main resources
from an Argo CD perspective
is the application resource.
The application resource typically tells
where my source code needs to come from
and which cluster is it destined to.
In this case, we have the
source coming from myRepo
and it is going to the demo cluster.
But what exactly is demo cluster?
How does Argo CD know
what this random string called
demo cluster really means?
Let's put a pin on it.
It'll become evidently clear
as we go through the next slides.
There's also an attribute
called (indistinct).
Again, I want to put a pin on it.
In subsequent slides we will cover
how project plays a role
in this entire setup.
Anytime you want to use a
cluster as a valid target
for your Argo CD, you need to
first register it with Argo CD
and how do you register
your cluster with Argo CD?
You create a Kubernetes secret
and pass the special label
that you see on screen here.
You give the cluster
and name the demo cluster
which we previously referenced.
So this is where the mapping
between the actual cluster
to the ARN happens.
In a typical self-managed installation.
Instead of the ARN, you'll be providing
the Kubernetes API server URL.
With EKS managed capabilities,
you don't have to worry about the URL,
you can just specify
the ARN and it'll work.
Similar to the clusters
we also need to register
all of our source repos
and how do you go about
registering the source repos?
The same as clusters.
You create another secret in
Kubernetes of type repository
and you will be able to connect to any
of your private GitHub,
GitLab or Bitbucket clusters.
The good thing about
that is EKS capabilities
comes integrated with AWS Secrets Manager.
So if you want to store
all of your Git secrets
in Secrets Manager, you can store that
and just reference the
Secrets Manager ARN.
What this means is we do not pull any
of the Secrets Manager credentials
into the cluster and store it.
It is just read at runtime authenticated
and it remains in Secrets Manager.
Typically, in a production environment,
you do not want everyone deploying
any quote to any cluster.
There needs to be certain
security guardrails.
App project is the way how Argo
CD enforces this constraints
app project, you can think about it
as what are my valid source repos
where the code can come from?
What are my valid destination clusters
where my source code can reach?
And who can really deploy those?
And that is defined by the Argo RBAC
that is highlighted here.
So Argo CD app project
acts as the container
which gives you that security boundaries.
Next, take a look at some of
the EKS specific integrations
that comes with the Argo CD capability.
In this particular case,
we are pulling a Helm chart from ECR.
So if you see the repos URL,
it's not a GitHub URL
instead it is an OCI URL.
What this really means
is with respect to any of
the EKS specific integrations
like ECR, you do not really have to create
a repository secret or do
the credential managements.
The capability IAM role can
automatically authenticate
into your ECR repository
and pull your Helm charts
into your cluster.
With self-managed installations,
that is not going to happen.
You have to install the repository secret
and worry about the
credentials management.
The same thing goes with AWS CodeCommit.
AWS CodeCommit, you again specify
just the URL of CodeCommit
the IAM role can automatically
authenticate into it.
You don't have to worry
about credential management
or creating any of the repository secrets.
There's one more integration that we have
it's called AWS CodeConnections.
CodeConnections lets you
connect to your GitHub, GitLab
or Bitbucket without managing
personal access tokens or secrets.
The way it works is
through an OAuth handshake.
You need to first register it
once with your Git provider
and once the authentication
is established,
you can directly reference it
from your Argo CD applications.
Again, the authentication's
automatically handled for you.
You don't have to create the credentials,
you don't have to worry
about managing the secrets.
So what are the key takeaways?
The key differentiators is
there is direct integration
with multiple AWS services
like Secrets Manager.
There is ECR CodeCommit,
CodeConnection, so it simplifies
how you connect to different
source repositories
to the Argo CD instance.
This is unique to EKS
capability for Argo CD.
Now let's take a look at what is ACK?
ACK or AWS Controllers for Kubernetes
let's you manage AWS
resources using Kubernetes
custom resources alongside
your applications.
Define an S3 bucket or an
RDS database in a YAML file
and apply it to your Kubernetes cluster.
And ACK handles the rest for you
of provisioning those resources.
ACK is again built on GitOps principles
with continuous drift
detection and reconciliation.
So ACK can always make sure
that whatever you have defined
within your Kubernetes
cluster is a source of truth
and when something deviates,
it can bring it back to the desired state.
How do we go about
creating an ACK capability?
Like we previously said,
all the capabilities follow
the same creation pattern.
You tell what type of capability you want,
which cluster you want it on.
What is the name of the capability
and what is the IAM role that
the capability should assume.
This is just showing it
through the Console as well.
I will quickly skip it.
Here is an example of an ACK resource.
In this case, we are
creating an S3 bucket.
If you look at it,
it just looks like any
other Kubernetes resource,
but if you note the kind is bucket.
Bucket is not a native API
that is supported by Kubernetes
it is a custom resource
and this is enabled by the ACK controllers
that are enabled by the ACK capability.
So once you apply this
particular Kubernetes
YAML tier cluster, it is
basically going to create
an S3 bucket with the name
that you have specified
and the policies that you
have defined for versioning
and blocking the public access.
IAMRoleSelector.
IAMRoleSelector is a
really important concept
for sophisticated ACK deployments.
It lets you map multiple
different IAM roles
to different name spaces.
It also enables cross
region resource management,
team isolation and
least privileged access.
The IAM role you specify here
is used by matching namespace.
In this case the ACK target account role
is used by namespace, which is production.
And anything starting with broad hyphen,
if you do not want namespace
specific roles, it's fine.
Just get rid of the namespace selector
and it'll apply cluster wide.
It's completely flexible.
It's up to you how you want to manage it.
Let's say you want to do cross region
deployments using ACK.
It is as simple as just
specifying the annotation
for the region and the sources
will be automatically provisioned
in the corresponding regions.
Let's say you have Kubernetes cluster,
there are multiple teams working on it.
They all have different
resources, different requirements
for spinning up different
resources within AWS
and they all need different permissions.
How do you go about doing it?
You basically can define
multiple different IAMRoleSelector
have multiple roles
and assign them to different name spaces.
Kubernetes RBAC Controls, who
has access to those different
namespaces and IAM permissions controls,
what resources they can spin?
So this way you can also operate
a multi-tenant ACK environment
in a single cluster.
Key takeaways from an Argo CD perspective.
So we have seen key two
capabilities so far.
One is Argo CD and the other one is ACK,
Argo CD handles the application deployment
with direct AWS integrations.
ACK handles infrastructure provisioning
with sophisticated IAM patterns.
This covers the deployment
and infrastructure,
but developers still need to worry about
the underlying resources.
How do we abstract that
for our developers?
And that's why Kro comes in.
Kro also known as Kube
Resource Orchestrator
let's platform teams create
custom Kubernetes APIs
by composing existing resources.
Think about it this way, if
you have a web application,
a web application could be
composed of a deployment,
a service, an ingress,
it can have an S3 bucket
and an RDS database.
Today, developers need to
know about all of that.
Would it not be convenient if
you can combine all of them
into one entity and call
it as web application?
So platform teams can create
a new customer resource
using Kro on the fly
called as web application
and they just allow certain things
to be configurable by the developers.
Developers do not need to know
the underlying complexity.
They can just create instances
out of the web application
by passing some basic
parameters using simple YAML
and they don't have to worry about
any of the underlying complexity.
Creating a Kro capability
is similar to what we saw
with the ACK capability.
I'm not going to dive into the details.
Only changes, the type of the capability
is going to be Kro in this
case instead of Argo CD or ACK.
The same thing can be
done through Console.
I'm going to quickly skip that.
And now we come to
resource graph definition,
which is the core to how Kube
Resource Orchestrator works.
The resource graph definition
is where platform teams
define custom APIs.
You encode your best practices here.
The schema section defines
what field developers can configure.
In this case, they can
specify the app name,
the number of replicas of the web app
and whether they need
an RDS database or not.
The resources section
defines what gets created.
The RGD creates a web
application resource type
in this particular case.
This is what developers
really need to create.
The platform engineers
have created the RGD.
When developers need to
create a web application,
it's as simple as this, they come,
they create a custom resource
of type web application.
They specify the name, they
tell how many replicas they need
and whether they need the database or not.
And you can make this as simple
and as sophisticated as you want.
Kro also empowers you
with the power of prescriptive patterns.
Developers only need to know, to specify,
let's say the name and region
when creating an S3 bucket.
In this particular case,
an S3 bucket is embedded
within a Kro RGD definition
with all the best practices built in.
The platform team has
already encoded saying that
whenever somebody in my
organization creates an S3 bucket,
it needs to come with versioning enabled.
The lifecycle policies
for cost optimization,
public access is blocked
and encryption is enabled.
So if you really think about it,
these settings are immutable
from a developer perspective.
They create the S3 bucket,
but the best practices are
already encoded for you.
When the platform administration team
has distributed the different RGDs.
Let's say you need to make an update
as part of platform engineering
to your existing RGD
and you want to change
the lifecycle policy
of retention from 90 days to 30 days
and add intelligent tiering,
you make the change to RGD,
deploy to your clusters.
All the underlying resources
automatically get the updates.
It's completely opaque.
Completely opaque from
a developer standpoint
as they do not even know
that the change has happened.
Versioning resource cloud definition means
that platform teams can evolve
their abstractions over time
and this is very critical
for large organizations
with many teams with
backward compatibility.
Standards are enforced through
code and not documentation.
One of the cool things about Kro
is that it comes with something
called a CEL expressions.
CEL expressions is how you embed logic
into your resource graph definition.
As you see here, in this
resource graph definition
for your production and environment,
it comes with larger DB instance
sizes with multi AZ enabled
and also the backup
retention is for 30 days
as against seven days for
non-production environments.
So you can quote this kind
of logic within your RGDs
depending on the type of
instances that created,
it'll make sure that these
policies are applied for you.
With independent customer resources,
customers would need to
work out of the order
of these resources, inject
configuration across them
and create custom patterns
for teams to consume.
Now let's see how that changes with Kro.
With Kro you can easily
create composable abstractions
and group different resources together.
So if there are certain resources
that need to get created
before other resources,
you can control the order.
In this case, let's say for example,
the VPC needs to be created
before the cluster gets created.
You can control that,
so that Kro waits for
the VPC to be created
grabs the VPC ID, passes on
to the EKS cluster creation
before the EKS cluster gets created.
All these three capabilities work together
to create a complete platform
engineering solution.
Kro provides the abstraction layer.
ACK handles AWS resource provisioning.
Argo CD handles the GitHubs deployment.
IAMRoleSelector ensures
proper permissions.
This is modern platform
engineering in AWS.
What are the key takeaways?
These features demonstrate
why EKS capabilities
is more than just manage installations.
They provide deep AWS integrations
and sophisticated IAM patterns
that aren't available with
self-managed solutions.
This is infrastructure
management designed for AWS.
With that, I will pass it on to Jesse
to cover the next slides.
- Thanks, Sriram.
Hey, thanks everybody for
kind of following along
with all of the how to get started
and watching all of the details fly by.
I wanted to call out that
we have documentation,
we have blogs, we have these things
you don't have to
actually remember at all.
There's a lot to cover as well,
which we're just sort of
touching the surface here.
So I think we'll have more
content as we move forward
and we'll have workshops
and things like that.
So I just wanted to call that out
and we're giving a very
high level treatment.
As part of that, before
you leave the room today,
I wanted to give you some considerations
when you're thinking about capabilities,
you know primarily like which
ones you'd want to choose
for which types of workloads
or what type of requirements you have,
what your governance
and operational model is
or you want it to be.
What multi cluster system
designs might look like
and how that impacts
multi-tenancy considerations.
And also like permissions,
lease privilege principle
and things like that where you
want to actually plan ahead
before you start clicking
buttons and onboarding teams.
How do you want to
manage those permissions
and how do you want to
design that into the future
so you can scale.
And obviously there's considerations on
using self-managed open source components
versus using capabilities.
So these are all things that
you should be thinking about
as you start kicking the tires
and looking at this set of features.
So EKS services are
designed to interoperate,
but they're not required to do so.
This is the first thing to think about.
If you only want to use Argo CD, you can.
If you're only interested
in Kro, that's fine.
These are designed to work together,
but they're all independent.
We also support any compute type on EKS,
whether it's hybrid nodes, auto mode
or self-managed nodes,
anything in between.
So there's some really powerful stuff
when you can hit a button in
the console, click a few more
and have an auto mode cluster
with all three capabilities,
but you don't need to
use auto mode with it.
You see, these are all kind
of our primitive features
are meant for you to design
and build the system that you need.
So operational model is
probably the biggest thing
you wanna look at as you
start automating a lot more
of your infrastructure and your workloads.
So centralized management
is sort of the classic
platform engineering model
where we see their
centralized management cluster
or fleets of management clusters.
We're working to orchestrate workloads
and multiple cloud resources
across the workload clusters.
So your onboard teams
probably into name spaces
or other type of tenancy model
and you're gonna be
provisioning AWS resources
and clusters through
the management cluster
or management clusters,
This can really simplify
operation for teams,
but it's a bit more of a burden
on a platform engineering
dedicated investment.
Whereas decentralized might
help you actually achieve
a little more velocity upfront.
But there are trade offs to
consider around each cluster
and each team having
some amount of autonomy.
Can you keep compliance in check?
Can you do your audits right?
That's where actually
GitOps comes in really handy
as far as the extensibility of that system
being literally anything, it's all in Git
it's all verifiable and it's
all immutable artifacts.
So you kind of get the
best of both worlds here
where you can start fast, but
you can keep it on the rails.
So I think the thing to
think primarily about is
how many teams do you have, will you have,
and how much autonomy might
they need in the future?
Multi cluster system designs is sort of
the bread and butter of
modern platform engineering.
With Kubernetes having that
management control plane,
what does that look like?
There's hub and spoke and
there's local cluster.
So these are really the two options.
Primarily we see, most
very scaled customers
with very mature large
platform engineering teams
prefer hub and spoke, because
it centralizes operations
and costs around managing
these components.
Whereas with local cluster
we see that a lot more
with scaling platform engineering efforts
or when a large organization
has multiple efforts
that are all working
independently from each other,
you know, potentially
different business units.
There's trade-offs here to consider,
particularly around scale and
how much you expect a team
to be able to take on operational burden
until it starts becoming a situation
where your small decentralized
teams start building
their own dedicated platform
engineering efforts,
that probably isn't ideal.
So those are the trade-offs
you look at for scale now,
but also into the future.
It's really, really important
to respect both IAM and RBAC
and the cluster, how they work together,
especially bringing Argo CD to the party
that has additional RBAC controls.
When you want to, think
about this in a continuum
of defense in depth, but also
just in specification, right?
Think about IAM as in the capability role
and in other roles that
you would use potentially
with IAMRoleSelector as
granting service permissions
to the capability.
This is what the capability can do
or can be configured to do
versus the controls in the cluster
about who can do what,
where, pardon my voice.
So this RBAC is gonna control
the Kubernetes resources
and where they can be created.
These are intimately connected,
particularly if an Argo CD application
defines a Kro specification,
which creates ACK resources.
Now you're talking about
anyone with access to be able
to create that resource in your cluster.
Having access to create
those AWS resources in your accounts.
This is transparent and it's very obvious
probably to us sitting in the room,
but it's something to
really get fluent with
when you start designing
out systems at scale,
it's very powerful.
It's just like Terraform
or Ansible and Salt
and you know things before it.
It's when you think about
infrastructure as code,
you're really talking about
taking the keys to the kingdom
and putting them at somebody's keyboard.
So you have to think about that.
With Kubernetes RBAC,
you have that little next level of defense
saying the system can
do these things in AWS,
but only these personas and
principles in the cluster
can do them.
The key takeaways on all
of these observations,
and there's many more, we're
actually gonna be building
some of these considerations
into extensive narratives
and guidance for our best practices guide.
The things to take away right now
as you start looking at
this and thinking about
how you might be able to use
it either as a scaling customer
or somebody with a mature
platform effort already
is how you want to simplify operations.
Is it simpler for you to have
a push button GitOps for
teams to get started?
Do prescriptive resources
actually make sense
to put teams on the rails
for some self-service, right?
Or do you actually need to
potentially for regulated
workload requirements
or just organizational standards,
do you need to consolidate
into a platform team?
If you already have a mature platform team
are you planning for scale?
Do you know where you're headed?
And can capabilities help offload some
of the foundational pieces?
Likely, if you're a mature platform team,
you already have an enormous amount
of differentiated value
built into your platform
that we would never presume to replace,
but these foundational
components can maybe free you up
for building more of that.
Ultimately, you wanna build
and ship faster and safer.
So with EKS capabilities,
this is our next step
and our next set of evolution of features
to help you do that.
We are continuing to execute,
which is one of the reasons
I love being in this service
still after six years,
we're continuing to execute
on this vision to help you focus
on building and shipping software
and not on managing the
small pieces of a cluster
that all of your colleagues
at the conference
also have to do.
Anything that we find as a commonality
we're gonna try and do on your behalf.
So you can offload that
undifferentiated heavy lifting to us
and you can focus on your
differentiated value.
So before we leave, I wanted to call out
some additional sessions at the conference
and some resources.
So there's some sessions here
that are worth taking a look at
builder session and two workshops.
These are gonna be foundational GitOps
and platform engineering content for you.
I believe these workshops,
some of them are self-driven as well.
We have a ton of workshop
content and learning materials
through our websites and
also session resources.
We always have our documentation,
EKS workshop, EKS blueprints.
These are all of the things
that come along with the service.
We support all of these directly.
So if you ever have ideas for new content
or you find yourself looking
and want to learn something
that we're not quite covering,
let us know and we're happy
to help you with that.
Thank you so much. Thanks
for taking your time.
I hope the rest of the
conference is great for you.
If you see us in the hall,
please flag us down and
we're happy to talk.
Thanks a lot.